[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so I told you earlier this
week that there is a tape a Trump Cohen
tape recorded by his former personal
attorney Michael Cohen who's become a
pretty significant character in this
entire Trump Russia investigation at
this point
CNN obtained the tape and we're gonna
listen to a little bit of it and what
they're going to be talking about if you
have not been following the context and
I don't blame you and in fact I envy you
if that's the situation that you're in
this is a conversation between Trump and
Michael Cohen related to Playboy model
Karen McDougal
with whom Trump had an affair allegedly
at the end you're gonna hear Trump
talking about paying cash and you're
gonna hear Michael Cohen say no no no
two important things I want to mention
about this which have been mentioned
elsewhere but not so much recently
number one the cash issue before we play
the tape Rudy Giuliani has been claiming
or had been claiming for the last few
days when there was a transcript of the
tape but not the tape itself that
referencing cash for the payment had
been attributed in the transcript to
Donald Trump when in reality it was
Michael Cohen who brought up the issue
of paying cash you will listen to the
tape and you will see that it's actually
very very clearly Donald Trump who
mentions cash and then it's Cohen who
says no no no that's number one
there's also another part of the tape
which I don't even know if we're gonna
play this may be before we actually pick
up jump into it we're Donald Trump
references Pam and that increasingly is
being considered to maybe be a reference
to Pam Bondi the beleaguered Florida
Attorney General with whom Trump has had
sketchy dealings including a very
interestingly timed campaign donation
which coincided of course just mere
coincidence with the dropping of
Florida's interest in investigating
Trump University so that was at the
beginning
the tape let's now get into the tape
sort of in the heat of it where Donald
Trump and his then personal attorney
Michael Cohen are talking about how to
handle this Karen McDougal story about
her affair with Donald Trump
we got served from the New York Times I
told you this will require a lot to
unseal the divorce papers with Ivana
we're fighting it Catholics is going to
never never never catch doesn't don't
ever be able they don't have a they
don't have a legitimate birth of a woman
that doesn't correct some in handling
yes and it's all for about two three
weeks now you have to do is delay
influence even after that it's not going
to ever be opened there's no there's no
purpose for told you about Charleston I
need to open up a company for the
transfer of all of that info regarding
our friend David you know so that I'm
gonna do that right away I've actually
come upon it all to me and I've spoken
to Alan why superb about how to set the
whole thing up with a funding yes and
it's all the stuffing all the stuff
because here you never know where that
company you never know what he's gonna
get
correct so I'm I'm all over that and I
spoke to Alan about it when it comes
time for the financing which will be
listen what my name's will have to do so
oh I got so there is zero question
whatsoever that it's Donald Trump who
says what financing we're gonna pay cash
and Michael Cohen says no no no no go so
this is all water under the bridge for
trumpets they are already convinced that
there's nothing here they are saying
that the tape is too muddled to really
understand anything
obviously we we had no problem
whatsoever understanding this tape there
are a few things here okay Trump's new
lawyer Rudy Giuliani
is saying that the content of this tape
simply doesn't matter because they never
ended up making the payment this is
evidence that a payment was discussed
not evidence that a payment was made the
biggest thing I guess I don't know what
else did the the biggest element of this
that to me
is the most notable is that yet again
Trump is caught lying and this is
someone Karen McDougal about whom rumors
of affair were dismissed by Trump is
totally fake news obviously the affair
happened obviously Trump lies about
everything he's pretending to barely
even know who Karen McDougal was clearly
bogus given that he was having a
conversation with Michael Cohen about it
where he didn't seem to need to be clued
into any of the details he seemed to
know them and if you're waiting around
for trumpets to care about the lies that
ship has sailed okay that's not going to
happen
Trump claimed to know nothing about it
denied the affair entirely and now he's
on tape talking about paying her cash
criminality here as always possible
campaign finance law violations we just
don't know yet we need to see they claim
no payment was ever made do I believe
that well I certainly don't take their
word for it because they've been lying
about this all along Cohen also on the
tape admits to opening up another one of
these shell companies that should be
notable but that's par for the course at
this point that's how these people
operate Cohen opens up shell companies
and then makes payments of hush money to
people that have had affairs with Donald
Trump it's the same story with stormy
Daniels that makes the stormy story even
more plausible since she was also paid
out of a shell company created by
Michael Cohen so that's all the same
pattern the most interesting aspect of
this is that when word broke about this
tape I immediately thought if the feds
have this tape there are probably more
tapes and there's a new report out now
which says the feds probably have at
least 12 audio recordings if not more
from Michael Cohen and I maintain that
if someone can bring cut bring Donald
Trump down it is Michael Cohen
so what's Trump's reaction predictable
reaction going on PBS Newshour I'm just
kidding obviously going on Twitter where
else is he gonna go and saying quote
what kind of a lawyer would tape a
client so sad is this a first never
heard of it before
why was the tape so abruptly terminated
cut while I was presumably saying
positive things I hear there are other
clients and many reporters that are
taped can this be so too bad of course
Trump's media Lackey Sean Hannity
all over this framing the tapes is
nothing teasing the story as mumbled a
jumbled unintelligible tapes that don't
say anything notable anyway he actually
teased the segment like last night by
saying when we come back we have
breaking news the Cohen Trump audio is
out I'll give you a hint a huge dud dud
dud
straight ahead well I think more tapes
are coming right and maybe this one was
released on purpose because it's kind of
ambiguous like you don't know for sure
if Trump is suggesting that they should
make a cash payment right and maybe the
idea behind that is to catch Trump and
his lawyers in a lie right deny that it
ever happened and then you release more
tapes clearly showing that it did yeah
the next tape you have Trump on on tape
saying Michael here is a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in cash
it is mostly 50s with some twenties
mixed in please count it make sure it
gets to Karen McDougal who I had sex
with and then of course they would say
listen that's a very muddled audio tape
and it that could be anybody we don't
know what that means what it was
definitely doctor that's that gonna be
the new excuse it's it's a fake tape the
tape is fake and did you know it's
incredible what Baron can do with
computers these days that could have
been anybody and it's completely
fabricated we'll see what happens but I
agree with Pat I think that we will see
more tapes eventually and they're not
going to be good for Donny boy remember
more than more than a year ago at this
point almost two years I mean feels like
10 years ago
when Donald Trump gave carrier
air-conditioning company a bunch of
money to keep a factory in Indiana
instead of moving something like a
thousand workers to Mexico and then
Trump claimed I did it I heroically
fixed and improved the economy by giving
money to this one company and what I
said at the time and I know many of you
were listening to the show watching the
show at the time and you'll remember me
saying this at the time I said this
isn't policy this isn't a change in the
economic and business environment that
led carrier to say I think we should
move these jobs to Mexico because we're
going to be better off financially by
doing that when you go and you give a
handout to one company and you get them
to make the opposite decision that the
market would have dictated you're not
fixing the economy at large you're not
changing
the economy at large all you're doing is
giving a company money to stay it's
effectively a bribe and of course it
failed hugely at the time carrier almost
immediately admitted that actually over
the long term the money they got from
Trump they were gonna use to automate
that Factory anyway are those those uh
job roles they were going to ultimately
move half of those thousand jobs to
Mexico anyway and it was an absolute and
total failure it was a band-aid but it
was like a crappy old band-aid that
barely had any adhesive left to stick to
your finger and you can barely even
really call it a band-aid at this point
an off-brand band-aid it was just an
adhesive bandage it was an adhesive
bandage that was not even waterproof it
was horrible whatever analogy however
far you want to go with the analogy and
now we have the exact same thing but
it's actually worse because now Donald
Trump is handing out money to try to put
a band-aid on a problem that he created
by choice the problem of the trade war
Trump's trade war a war he can't win a
war that was optional is optional has
crushed American farmers crushed
American farmers I've been telling you
about this most of these farmers are in
red states and most of them at least
mathematically are Republicans they are
Trump voters and their Republican
elected officials are understandably
upset about what's going on so what
Donald Trump has now come up with to do
is he's put together a 12 million dollar
I'm sorry 12 billion dollar emergency
fund for the farmers and farmers are
going to start getting payments because
they're getting crushed because of
Trump's trade war does anybody
understand how stupid this is does
anybody care the so-called fiscal
conservatives how fiscally irresponsible
this is you start a trade war with the
idea that I guess in some long-term way
it's going to be good for the country
it's gonna be good for American
businesses it's gonna be good for
workers we know it's not going to be
good economists say you can't win this
there's evidence that it's not good
because we are already seeing American
farmers get completely and totally
crushed so instead of looking at undoing
the bad economic policy in the first
place
Trump makes the decision
to compound the economic disaster by
spending 12 billion dollars of your
money on aid to farmers which will of
course much like giving money to carry
our air conditioner it's not going to
fix the problems that the trade war is
creating in the first place it's you
start with bad policy and then you put
bad policy on top of that what would
help farmers is fix the tariffs so that
they can get more access to foreign
markets instead of just giving them cash
and where are the fiscal conservatives
remember that when President Obama
bailed out the auto industry it was a
loan that was going to be repaid to
taxpayers with interest and at least the
portions that were loaned out under
Obama because remember some of it came
back from the Bush administration the
portions loaned out under Obama have
been paid back and Republicans still
went nuts saying you can't choose
winners and losers Obama didn't choose
winners and losers he gave out loans to
be paid back this is actually choosing
winners and losers it's saying here are
the farmers that are losing because of
the trade policy and we're gonna throw
cash at them - at least on paper keep
them as winners disastrous embarrassing
policies yeah and while the bankers
wanted to bail out it doesn't appear
like the farmers want one themselves I
don't know I don't know that I mean
they're suffering and they've said some
of them have been interviewed and
they've said well we we know these
things can take a while but in the short
term they're getting crushed and I don't
see them turning the money away anyway
that's right but they're also some of
the hardest workers in the entire
country yeah they want to pull
themselves up by their bootstraps and
you know this is all a result of an
unforced error it's not like it's the
result of a famine or no out or
something and there's actually something
horribly brilliant about what Trump is
doing here as political strategy as
usual I have no idea if Trump is aware
of this if somebody that's working for
Trump is aware of this farmers should
punish Trump in November for ruining
their businesses and their livelihoods
they should not vote for the Republicans
that allowed Trump to do the trade war
and in 2020 they should definitely not
vote for Trump either Trump starts this
trade war and it crushes the farmers but
then he says listen I had to do it they
were ripping us off we were being
treated unfairly
but here's some money so that you'll be
okay and now those farmers need Trump
because it's much easier for whoever
replaces Trump or Democrats if they take
over for Republicans in the Senate in
the house to say we're not going to do
the 12 billion in payments any more than
it is for Trump to change trade policy
and now the very people being crushed by
Trump are being held hostage to Trump's
12 billion dollars in payments because
they need the money and there's a
particular type of evil genius here and
don't forget that this was all caused by
Republicans the Republican president
starts the trade war the
republican-controlled House and Senate
allows it to happen
remember that Trump slammed Canada for
subsidizing their dairy industry which
made American dairy less competitive
what's Trump doing now by giving money
to farmers in the US it allows them to
charge less and end up with the same
amount of money because of the 12
billion in payments it is the same type
of subsidy that Trump slammed when it
was Canada doing it we are in total
idiocracy and i want to hear from you
about this i'm on twitter at des Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and boy do we have a good one for
you today the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com okay let's say major major
thank you to two great people I want to
say thanks to silver Corbin who is
today's new david pakman show member of
the day also jeffrey huh spec who's been
with us since 2012 almost six years of
membership for Jeffrey and not quite six
years for silver but well on their way
both to total and complete deification
by the David Pakman show
join them at WWJ on comm or make a
pledge of as little as one dollar a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show
alright the much awaited
much-anticipated
very very exciting moment of the week
for many people and also something that
some people can't stand it's time for
hatred mail we're so all right it's
wrong patriot mail written by patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom all right it's been
a little while since we had a
straight-up anti-feminist sort of men's
rights activist esque patriot mail and
that's exactly what we've got this week
let's take a listen to it together and
see if we can make heads or tails out of
it yeah ah Pakman you're miss and rest'
feminist agenda is showing you can't
seem to accept there are differences
between men and women this ping me to
anti male agenda has hijacked the
liberal wing and it's sickening
so basically get over at you ball s
wonder David Pakman is a paid actor for
the New World Order agenda he's been
exposed David Pakman hates America
confirmed so anytime you hear my name in
reverb like that for people who aren't
reading the transcript that's when my
name is in triple parentheses which is
the calling card of the anti some
white nationalist types that's how they
identified Jewish individuals on the
internet by putting triple parentheses
in the way we're interpreting that for
hatred mail purposes is with a with a
sort of extraordinary reverb thing yeah
this is a listen number one the idea
that the david pakman show is known for
a feminist agenda this is sort of like
with the Islam thing where we
simultaneously take heat because I'm too
tough on Islam and also an apologist for
Islamic terror and the truth is that I
just call it like I see it and sometimes
I have one view on a particular
situation and sometimes another it's the
same thing with the feminist stuff right
like we did a piece long-form piece
about a gender pay gap and I pointed out
that a gender pay gap exists the 77
cents on the dollar is just flat-out
wrong it appears to be more like 91 or
so cents on the dollar and some element
of that nine cent difference certainly
would be due to discrimination against
women some part of that nine cent
difference the people who believe
there's no pay gap whatsoever said I'm a
you know feminist soy boy whatever and
I've been totally subjugated by the
feminist agenda and then the some of the
people on the feminist side said David
how dare you question that it's 77 cents
on the dollar it you're both wrong it's
just there is a pay gap some part of it
is due to discrimination against women
and it's about 91 cents on the dollar I
would think that that long-form piece
would just please everyone right no no
there's no sound like both sides win we
meet on the middle we got to the bottom
of it and the truth wins out rarely in
politics is the truth actually just in
the middle of the two extremes in this
case the idea that there's no pay gap
whatsoever and that it's 70 cents 77
cents on the dollar it happened to be
roughly in the middle and everybody was
still furious anyway this is not a myth
and restore Miss Andrus show a period
and if that's that's how you see it as
because that's what you want to see make
22 hey tree its cry by using the coupon
code hey tree at 40 when you sign up for
membership at WWJ Ann pakman.com coupon
code hey tree at 40
gets you a 40% discount and it gets 22
hey tree it's too shut its here and and
it's a big fu to the hatreds does that
number grow every week it doesn't
noticing that it goes up by one one or
two every single week we have the first
casualty from Sacha Baron Cohen's news
show who is America Baron Cohen is of
course the actor who has developed such
characters as Ali G Borat Bruno and in
this new show that he has on Showtime he
plays a new character he's an Israeli
firearms instructor named Iran Murad who
claims to support everything from burka
bands to training four-year-olds to use
firearms and he has gotten some really
high-profile interviews Pat including
everybody from I don't even know where a
standard Sanders hiyo Sarah Palin I
think realized that something wasn't Roy
Moore she bailed Roy Moore was
interviewed by him and today we have the
first casualty which is Jason Spencer
Jason Spencer's a Georgia state lawmaker
he was apparently so taken with kernel
Iran Murad that he ended up supporting a
burqa ban yelling the n-word incessantly
pretending to be an Asian tourists
during which he adopted a stereotypical
Asian accent and at one point actually
dropped his pants to quote use his
buttocks to intimidate Isis here is a
piece of the video n-word warning but I
think that his buttocks is going to be
blurred out for people that are watching
take a look at this because of who you
are you could be the victim of
kidnapping by Isis you have two seconds
to attract attention how do you attract
attention you start screaming take your
clothes off in America there is one
forbidden world it is the n-word now I
am going to be the terrorist you have
three seconds to attack the tension go
you crazy
the n-word is nuni not this world this
world is disgusting carrot
Isis are scared of being seen as Omo you
know it it mean Omo if your buttock
touch them it means they have become a
homosexual now I am going to teach you
how to use your buttocks to intimidate
Isis
show me the buttock no trousers down
okay go America good one more time but
louder with America
we say in the Mossad I mean not in the
Mossad if you want to win you show some
skin ok ok show it to me now
try to touch me I'll touch you touch you
with my bags I'll touch you you will
drop the gun I'll touch you
you are say ok stop you have to remind
me if I touch you you will become a
homosexual
ok now try to touch me go ok yes on you
show me your weapon go I'll make you a
homosexual you drop that gun right now
you had think okay the most incredible
thing is that when you watch this clip
Spencer's behavior is so insane and so
outrageous that it's actually hard to
believe he's not an actor and that this
is all scripted it's so wack that it
seems like Spencer is working for the
show but he wasn't and he's now
resigning after this he is blaming Sasha
Baron Cohen saying that he was taking
advantage of he put out a statement
through the Atlanta journal-constitution
saying that quote imposing is an Israeli
agent Cohen pretended to offer
self-defense exercises as uncomfortable
as I was to participate I agreed to
understanding that these quote
techniques were meant to help me and
others fend off what I believed was an
inevitable attack I deeply regret the
language I used at Cohen's request as
well as my participation in the class
general if I had not been so distracted
by my fears I never would have agreed to
participate in the first place obviously
the first thing anybody does when they
believe that their family may be at risk
is you go somewhere and you start
yelling the N word out incessantly like
you're having a grand old party and he's
framed himself as just being so scared
that he was scared into participating
because of fear for his family imagine
just for a second okay here's what I was
thinking about Pat you can get Jason
Spencer to say on camera the n-word like
it's a party
and fake an Asian accent what is he
willing to do behind the scenes and what
could a lobbyist get him to do by
offering him some money yeah I mean he
was totally exposed here right I don't
think I think he does genuinely believe
these things deep down and would say
these things in private I agree normally
you wouldn't do that on camera but he
was duped here and I think that's the
genius of Sasha Baron Cohen you're
better off that Jason Spencer is
resigning now a lot of people do have a
problem with what Sasha Baron Cohen is
doing they're saying you you are
misrepresenting the person that you are
and thus the entire thing is sort of
dishonest at its base I don't know that
that's a good that could be an argument
against Sacha Baron Cohen's of format
right that how he does what he does with
Ali G Borat whoever but that's not a
defense of Jason Spencer because I don't
care what costume Sacha Baron Cohen puts
on I'm not gonna start yelling the N
word out incessantly right it's just not
gonna happen I don't care what costume
or who he claims to be yeah I mean your
true colors are revealed here and some
people are failing the test others are
passing the test that's Bernie Sanders
for example he wasn't fooled by it he
could kind of pick up on the fact that
Sasha was playing a carrot and even
Sarah Palin and she as we're told
Sarah Palin identified that the person
claiming to be a so-called veteran of
the service was actually Sacha Baron
Cohen and was not a former service
member and walked out of the interview
not everybody is falling for this stuff
and we are all better off with Jason
Spencer resigning I think that there is
no question about that if you disagree
that Spencer should have to resign as a
result of this please let me know and
you can discuss it on the David Pakman
show
subreddit a david pakman.com
/re d di t the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it is great to be
joined today by david ferris was an
associate professor of political science
at roosevelt university also the author
of it's time to fight dirty how
Democrats can build a lasting majority
in American politics
David it's so great to have you on and
this idea of fighting dirty is of
particular interest right now because my
audience has been very split recently in
reaction to some of the tactics that
have been adopted by anti-trump
activists I guess we would call them
this includes ruining the meals at
Mexican restaurants of different Trump
administration officials and showing up
outside of Kristen Nielsen's condo and
playing audio of children crying at the
border and there's people in the
audience who say to me David we need to
take the high road because ultimately we
are going to be sort of our own judges
in the long run and we need to feel good
about the tactics that we're using we
don't want to stoop to their level and
the counter to that has been listen
you're dealing with people who are
ignoring all rules of decorum tone and
they are not going to be defeated unless
we do adopt some of these tactics so
let's start like at the broadest
possible level when we talk about
fighting dirty when you talk about it
what types of tactics are you referring
to sure I mean that's a great question
and thanks for having me on the show
today
I think when we talk about fighting
dirty we're not talking about like
cheating or lying we're talking about
sort of pressing the boundaries of
procedural norms and sort of pressing
the boundaries of legality and
constitutionality just as our opponents
have been doing I think over the last 20
years so it means things like using the
full constitutional power of the
minority in Congress to hold up
legislation
it means not cooperating with with the
president at all that is not giving
Democratic votes to Republican priority
is because sort of bipartisanship makes
the party in power look good and we
don't want that so I think that in terms
of this whole debate about you know
civility and you know whether it's okay
to confront people in restaurants I
would tend more towards the the
confrontational side of that debate I
think you know the best way to enjoy a
peaceful meal in DC is to not put
children in cages so I think that the
our activists are well within their
rights to do things that are very
confrontational I mean I think at the
same time you don't want to do things
that are deeply alienating to people
whose votes you need so I think the Jews
will always be a conversation about
whether a certain tactic is really gonna
work or whether it's not but if we
believe our own rhetoric that we're in
the midst of a crisis in the midst of an
emergency I do think that that means
that we can do certain things and pursue
certain tactics that we might not under
other circumstances so let's pick a
couple of the things you mentioned and
talk sort of through the pragmatics of
it because I agree in principle with for
example start holding up all the
legislation you can hold up a Supreme
Court nomination if you can so on and so
forth very quickly though you get to for
example because of the way that that our
House and Senate work where Democrats
are put in a position where unless they
because something that they want is
bundled in to a bigger Republican bill
or proposal unless they go along with
the Republican bill or proposal that
includes an amendment that contains
something that the Democrats want
they're simply not getting it I hate
that that's the way it is I don't
believe there's any rule that says that
that things have to be bundled together
in this way it is a deliberate political
tactic that is done but it happened so
what exactly do Democrats do in that
case well I mean I think first of all I
think that it's been very rare for
Republicans to actually be smart about
this because what they have done is
they've made the underlying legislation
that they're pushing so repugnant that
the things that they're offering as
these poison pills just aren't enough to
get Democrats to vote for things I think
the one the one time that they really
succeeded in doing this well was with
the chill
health insurance program during the
standoff over over taka and January in
February that worked really well but
since then we have seen Republicans in
Congress sort of allowing the president
to dictate this extremely regressive
unpopular agenda to them and so even
when you know even if they put goodies
into a bill that diminishes legal
immigration to the United States it's
not going to get Democratic votes
because they just can't afford to attach
themselves so it's a legislation that
toxic
I think occasionally something will come
up that is a moral imperative for
Democrats and I think that we have seen
them willing to do this and I think that
they should do this and I'm thinking of
something like funding the wall this
mythical wall in exchange for for the
dreamers that's a that's a you know
that's a compromise Democrats offered
Republicans and Republicans rejected it
so I think I'm only willing to
compromise when I think there's
something really morally imperative at
stake and that could be the dreamers
that could be something about family
separations that could be something
about the ACA for 99% of everything else
that's gonna come before Congress I'm in
favor of obstruction I have made it
pretty clear that I'm to the left of the
Democratic Party and I think that the
Democratic Party is is but by and large
to the right of the American people in
general but that being said it is sort
of the de-facto path for progressivism
right now because of the sort of
structural impediments that exist to
real third-party success and that that's
not really what we're going to talk
about today but it sort of sets up my
question to you which is is part of the
problem that Democrats just aren't to
the left enough on a lot of issues such
that the daylight between the Democrats
and the Republicans isn't big enough to
really take advantage from an activism
point of view on so many of the
structural issues campaign finance and
many others that that we could talk
about and I'm not someone to be clear
David that says there's no different
difference between Democrats and
Republicans I think the differences are
significant and they are numerous but on
some structural issues there isn't that
much difference and I wonder if that
holds back the ability to sort of do the
type of activism that usage
just sure I think that this is changing
a lot I think it's changed a lot over
the last two years I still see sort of
pieces of that older Democratic Party
that was not as distinguishable from
Republicans as we might like and I'm
thinking about something like when
seventeen Democratic senators voted to
roll back the dodd-frank bill earlier
this year that was the sort of
depressing repressive of the kind of
democratic politics that I think many of
us have become frustrated with over the
years in terms of some other issues
though I do think that there's more
difference between Democrats than there
was ten years ago I mean if you think
back to 2007 in the fight over
immigration reform there were still
Democrats in the party who voted against
comprehensive immigration reform know we
can have some problems with that
legislation anyway but the point is that
ten years ago there were a significant
number of Democrats in Congress who were
unwilling to sign on to a path to
citizenship for undocumented immigrants
or or help for the dreamers so I think
that's really changed over the last ten
years to the point where I think support
to the dreamers is like a litmus test
for being in the Democratic Party in the
same way that I think support for some
form of Medicare for All or single-payer
health insurance has become the default
sort of center of gravity in the party
and that's really really different than
it was ten years ago I think that there
are still some issues where there's a
lot of work to be done and I think that
that is in the party's relationship to
big business to corporations to drug
companies and you know that's that's
something that's gonna take a little bit
longer to shake out but I do think I'm
I'm heartened that I think that because
I think that energy is on the side of
these progressive activists who are
doing the really hard work of running
for elections of holding people
accountable and I think in the long run
they might not win every primary but I
do think that we did that side of the
party was winning a lot of policy fact
that it was losing ten or twenty years
ago
in part two of the interview we'll talk
about some of the specific areas you
think that that are good areas of focus
for activists and for Democrats but to
kind of set up that part of the
conversation we've talked about the way
in which gerrymandering in addition to
just the sort of urban-rural divide is a
structural disadvantage for Democrats
and
spoke to Bill Oh Goolsbee professor bill
Oglesby about that and sort of the
dynamics of that can you talk about
other than that what ways are sort of
illustrative of how Democrats are at a
structural disadvantage sure I think the
most important structural disadvantage
for Democrats is the US Senate the
Senate you know every state has the same
two senators you know according to the
Constitution whether you have 700,000
people like my oming or whether you have
38 million people like California over
time the way our politics have shaken
out this is given an enormous advantage
to small rural states like North Dakota
you know like Vermont Delaware but
they're mostly Republican right and
because this is uh namenda bull like the
Constitution says in order to change the
equal representation of the Senate you
have to have the state's consent you're
not going to get that so this is a
structural feature of our politics it's
unchangeable and Democrats have probably
you know a significant long-term deficit
in the Senate because there's 30 or 31
Republican leaning states and 20 or 21
democratic meeting states so that you
know in a vacuum Republicans will hold
the Senate more often than that don't
just by virtue of the sort of the
population dynamics of this country and
the way that states were created and and
the sort of the unique problem that we
have in this country I've looked we have
all of these like really tiny states
with very small populations so that that
is built into our politics in ways that
I think Democrats have been really slow
to recognize and to address how would
you address something like that well we
need more states so because we can't do
away with the Senate we can't abolish
the Senate and we can't we can't change
the equal representation in the Senate
what we really need is to create more
states that leave democratic and there's
easier and harder ways to do this the
sort of the low-hanging fruit has
statehood for Washington DC in Puerto
Rico
both of whom are significant entities
that have no representation in Congress
right now DC has had a referendum that
over one when we want to join the Union
Porto Rico is a little bit more
complicated story but I do think that
another referendum would would show that
the majority of Puerto Ricans would like
to join the United States is that
50 second or 51st state yeah you know
what order you want to do it in both of
those states would send two Democratic
senators to DC and it would help sort of
alleviate the imbalance that we see
structurally in the Senate and as we
know in recent American history
if these would control all three
branches of government you basically get
nothing done that's where our
partisanship is so we need to think
about these creative solutions we could
also talk about the US Virgin Islands or
Guam or any number of territories the
u.s. holds that could vote for statehood
and could join the Union as a very small
state now to the extent that that
Republicans hold the House and Senate
can they not simply prevent these
territories from obtaining statehood
even if by referendum they say we want
to do it oh yeah Republicans Republicans
recognize that DC would be a massive
partisan loss for them and they probably
recognize the Puerto Rico would be too
and so there others they're not going to
act on this I think that so part of part
of the idea here is that they sort of an
elaborate fantasy where Democrats take
power over the next two cycles and we
wake up in January 2021 in terms of the
entire federal government and the
question is like what do we do at it
because we need to address these
structural barriers to progressive power
just as just as importantly as we as we
focus on you know policy differences or
you know medicare for all all these
things those are important the policy
fights are important and the policies
are important but it's also important if
we're gonna win in 2022 or 2024 to just
take down some of these structural
barriers and we have to do so creatively
like within the constitutional framework
there's nothing stopping us from adding
States in part two of the interview
we're actually going to talk about some
of the other ideas that you have along
those lines we have been speaking with
David Farris who's an associate
professor of political science at
Roosevelt University the book is called
it's time to fight dirty how Democrats
can build a lasting majority in American
politics and we'll pick up the
conversation right there on tomorrow's
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so I've said before I don't really
believe in using this type of language
as legitimate political language but but
it's sort of is the right language to
use here
Trump's been totally cooked by Vladimir
Putin and I know that Pat gets very very
upset when I use that kind of language
and he pulls me aside after the show and
we often have to have a conversation
that that embarrasses max because of how
crazy it gets but he's been totally cut
by Putin who has rejected Trump's
invitation to the White House into
Washington DC one of the things that
came out of the Helsinki summit other
than the sort of undeniable obvious
confirmation that Trump is a total
captive of Vladimir Putin's is that
Trump wants Putin at the White House
they were calling it a sort of second
summit but this time not on neutral
ground like Helsinki but rather on Putin
oh sorry
Freudian slip on Trump's turf Washington
DC in the United States and it wasn't
really clear whether this was a good
idea or a bad idea
until yesterday when Russia announced
that they're gonna reject the invitation
they're rejecting Trump's offer for a
summit and it is making Trump once again
look like the humiliated fool that he is
getting played by world leaders all over
the world and when you think about one
of Putin's top goals as meddling in the
2016 election to destabilize American
democracy and to make Russia seem like a
power player the Alpha around the world
this is the exact message that is
reinforced when Russia says Oh Trump
invited Putin to the White House no
thanks this isn't the right time and for
the time being
Russia is saying no trouble atop Putin
Kremlin aid Yuri ochakov
said quote after the summit you know
what kind of atmosphere there is around
its outcome I think it would be wise to
let the dust settle and then we can
discuss all these questions in a
businesslike way but not now and this
invitation was not some random offhanded
statement from Trump just last week
Trump and White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said preparations
were already underway for the visit
right you don't say you're already
preparing for the visit unless you're
thinking about it as a serious thing and
now Putin says now can't be bothered
right now
maybe some other time Trump even tweeted
about it last week saying the summit
with Russia was a great success except
with the real enemy of the people the
fake news media I look forward to our
second meeting so that we can start
implementing some of the many things
discussed including stopping terrorism
security for Israel nuclear
proliferation cyberattacks trade Ukraine
Middle East peace North Korea and more
there are many answers some easy and
some hard to these problems but they can
all be solved
apparently not with Putin at the White
House though ouch totally played once
again right Putin is kind of like the
pickup artist and Trump is the naive
youngster who thinks he's such a nice
guy
why wouldn't I go on another date with I
was thinking that this was gonna stir up
Trump's daddy issues right I think Trump
has one of those complexes where his dad
never truly accepted him yeah so he was
always upset with himself right had to
have his dad bail him out so many times
with his business endeavors right I like
the same thing right if we think that
Trump is Putin working for Putin and yet
Putin won't even visit the White House
that's kind of shame him the art of the
deal this guy I mean can you think of a
worse deal maker than Trump in politics
Putin is just straight-up toying with
the guy but we got along so well in
Helsinki and now he says he doesn't want
to play in my sandbox how many times
from get humiliated by Putin before the
Trump is say enough is enough
sky is embarrassing our country
unfortunately it's a very very high
number I don't think I don't think we're
anywhere close to the number of times
Trump needs to get humiliated by Putin
before the trumpets will say this might
not be working out as well as the so
called the renewed friendship with
Russia was supposed to be working out
the trumpets don't care they're gonna
stick with them it could have been
Russia who declined the information the
invitation it could have been Israel who
declined the invitation it could've been
a 400-pound man sitting on a bed
somewhere who listen there's nearly 200
countries out there so the fact that
Russia is not coming to Washington DC
could actually relate to Equatorial
Guinea --hz decision or maybe the
Chilean President made the call could be
anybody tons of countries out there as
Donald Trump often likes to say I have
been telling you about the
Orwellian Newspeak that has been scaling
up from Trump and the administration
lately they're making claims that aren't
just inaccurate but the are they're the
exact opposite of reality in many cases
and I've said it before and I'll say it
again this is a strategy and this is a
strategy to make people question whether
they can believe anything that they hear
at all and we've talked about the
dynamics of how that works before if
Trump says I don't know pick a topic
stormy Daniels I don't know who she is
I met her we didn't pay anything we paid
but it was Cohen's money but I didn't
pay him back but I did pay him back all
of a sudden it becomes sort of like a
non-issue in the mind of Trump is
because they've heard every possible
side of that issue espoused by Donald
Trump at least at some point they don't
know what to believe they'll go back to
seeing the Red Sox Yankee game instead
and then not worry anymore about what
actually is the truth about stormy
Daniels Trump is now using this strategy
on Trump Russia he is now claiming that
he's worried that Russia will meddle in
the 2018 midterms to help Democrats this
is straight-up concern trolling check
out Trump's tweet from yesterday where
he said quote I'm very concerned that
Russia will be fighting very hard to
have an impact on the upcoming election
yeah okay well that part's true and he
goes on to say based on the fact that no
president has been tougher on Russia
than me they will be pushing very hard
for the Democrats they definitely don't
want Trump now of course none of that is
true there's no evidence that Russia is
trying to help Democrats Trump certainly
hasn't been the toughest president on
Russia and all the evidence is that
Russia does want Trump now I do want to
say okay before we get on to like the
bulk of the analysis Russia's goals are
broader than Trump per se so Trump is a
means to an end
he makes the u.s. look terrible he makes
Putin look better and stronger in
comparison he destabilizes American
democracy and makes people question
whether our democratic system is even
working it's possible that Russia would
help Democrats like if Russia determined
that that would be the next thing like
if Russia determined that okay
don't we help Trump win and and things
are crazy let's now create even more
chaos by helping Democrats achieve a
majority and a house senator both
because of how it will further unhinge
Trump that is how Russia thinks there's
just no evidence that that's actually
going on right now well yeah I mean it's
pretty clear that in 2012 they favored
Barack Obama over Mitt Romney right but
in twenty see what do you mean by that
well Romney was pretty tough on Russia
and oh they liked Obama more fair enough
but in the recent Helsinki summit Putin
said that he wanted Trump to win right
because that would normally is
normalized relations between the US and
Russia so this is gaslighting that's
ultimately what it is this is another
example of projection it's Orwellian
Newspeak where everything is the
opposite and this is now something that
someone is feeding Donald Trump I
actually don't think that Trump is
coming up with this himself anymore I
think that somebody is feeding to Trump
take the line that Russia wants the Dems
to win and this is also another de facto
attack on American intelligence by the
way Trump's not saying it in his tweet
and Trump's tweet he just says Russia
wants the Dems but we know that the
consensus of the intelligence community
is that Russia metal to help Trump when
Trump says the opposite when Trump says
I've been super tough on Russia and
Russia wants the Dems that sort of a de
facto way of Trump saying he doesn't
believe the intelligence community and
this is monstrous dangerous gaslighting
and it's only dangerous because people
will believe it and will be tricked by
it period if we had a voting public
overall that saw this and said that's
not true we know what the truth is and
this isn't it it wouldn't be so
dangerous but it's dangerous because
there are a lot of people out there who
are gonna believe this stuff and if we
needed more proof that Trump isn't
really worried about Russia hacking the
Democrats hacking to help Democrats
rather it's that he's doing nothing
about it right think about this for a
second if you're Trump or if you're a
Republican and you want Republicans to
win and you think Russia's helping
Democrats you would immediately try to
stop Russian meddling Trump hasn't tried
to stop Russian meddling and in fact he
said just last week how strong and tough
Putin was in his denials that meddling
even took place and additionally
Republicans just blocked a bid to a bill
rather to extend election security
grants
you run the House and Senate and you
think Russia is helping the Democrats
why would you block funding for election
security you would say hey we need to
stop it because Russia wants the Dems
none of them believe that that's what's
going on or those additional sanctioned
over assertions overwhelmingly passed by
Congress that Trump for the longest time
refused to implement they would say in
trying to implement them it's not insane
to say we can imagine why Russia might
want Democrats to win over Republicans
we could we could imagine that
circumstance but there's no evidence
that that's going on it goes completely
counter to what our intelligence
agencies are saying and three if anybody
believes that that's what Russia's doing
they're doing nothing to try to prevent
it which is what makes it abundantly
clear that this is a show it's a gong
show it's a joke and more importantly
it's working I was trolling some of the
not actually I wasn't posting anything
but I was sort of browsing some of the
known internet enclaves of the most
committed trumpets and they are they are
now saying Russia wants the Democrats
Russia wants the Democrats to win and we
need to vote in November because
otherwise Russia and the Dems will take
the House and Senate so it's working
any harebrained notion that is presented
by Trump is now being taken as gospel by
trumpet and that's why this stuff is so
abundantly dangerous
we got a voicemail yesterday attempting
to call me out for glaring hypocrisy on
media freedom and to refresh your memory
on Monday I did a story basically
summing up the multi-faceted war on a
free and independent press that Donald
Trump is waging this includes starting
to use the term enemy of the American
people when referring to the media
attacks on individual media outlets as
fake news talking about the possibility
of journalism licenses sending out this
completely whacked-out survey to
Republicans asking push poll questions
about who's the least fair to trump
who's the most dishonest when reporting
about Trump so I described
on Monday and then I got the following
voicemail at our voicemail number two
one nine to david p take a listen to it
so trump trashed the media and then you
trashed trump for it but you transfer
media every show every show you ask for
money because hey independent media is
so much better than the rigged paid for
media right if we had a media that
worked there would have been a vietnam
war there wouldn't have been a war on
Iraq and probably a dozen other ones
yeah listen these are two separate
things okay I'm trying to think about
how to even explain this so one of the
things I do on the show is when there
are biased media reports or false
balance and media or incorrect reporting
or whatever I describe it to you I
analyze it I give my critique and I say
many times that if you want to increase
the diversity of voices in media it's
good to in addition to paying your cable
bill or doing whatever else you do if
you do that it's good to also support
independent shows like the David Pakman
show that is not me attacking the
institution of a free and independent
press right these are two totally
different things
Trump framing media as the enemy of the
American people is not the same as me
saying look at the crazy fake debate
that they had on Fox News right these
are two totally different things and I
hope that the reason I'm struggling to
explain it is because most of our
audience kind of gets that yeah
different things Pat it's like two
unconnected things can be true at the
same time yes right that's right it can
be daytime and also cold at the same
time huh it could be day or night it
could be cold or warm and these things
can happen and I guess four different
combinations or whatever the number is
yeah listen
that there's my critiques of independent
media of individual media outlets have
nothing to do with my defensive media as
one of the most treasured and
fundamentally important institutions of
American democracy
see to the extent that it still exists
and we want it to exist we've got a
great bonus show for you today
a waiter admits that the racist note he
claimed to have received from diners was
fake
the waiter made it up we will talk about
that we will talk about Donald Trump's
new effort to revoke security clearances
of ex-intelligence officials who have
criticized him there's a nice little
idea and I will issue Pat a public
defense of Public Libraries I believe
public libraries are still an important
staple of the Commons and rel relevant
even in 2018 so that'll be what's more
exciting than me talking about libraries
come on very few things
ww join pakman.com to get access to the
bonus show you can also access it by
becoming a $5 a month or hire a member
on patreon at patreon.com slash david
package
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]